[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein ruck zuck
blechkuchen nämlich den bienenstich den
bienenstich kennt ihr alle da wird ja
normalerweise aus hefeteig gemacht und
dann kommt da vanillepudding krähen
dazwischen heute machen wir es ein
bisschen anders wir vereinfachen das
ganze rezept aber wir haben am ende
einen richtig leckeren blechkuchen hier
zeige ich euch die zutaten wenn wir
machen jetzt zuallererst den teig dafür
benötigen wir eier auf zimmertemperatur
im allerbesten außerdem zucker vanille
zucker und salz hier an trockenen
zutaten habe ich alles schon in einer
schüssel nämlich mehlspeise stärker und
backpulver ich meinte vanille extrakt
aber wer den nicht bekommen dann gibt es
übrigens auch im shop der kann auch ein
päckchen vanillezucker nimmt hier sind
die zutaten für den wandel belag wir
benötigen sahne wieder vanille extrakt
oder zucker werk ein extrakt butter und
zucker und natürlich gehobelte mandeln
und ich beginne jetzt damit in dem ich
hier zuallererst alle vier zutaten das
heißt seine vanille butter und zucker in
einen topf geben
auf mittlerer stufe aufkochen und dann
so langsam zum küchen bringe und das
ganze für eine minute
nachdem wir die gehobelte mandeln mit
zum masse gegeben habe und gut
untergerührt einfach zurück in die
schüssel geben und dann so zehn minuten
lang auskühlen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit gehen wir über zur maschine
die eier sind ja hier schon drin und da
kommt jetzt auch mal die prise salz mit
dazu das hilft einfach dass die eier
sich besser aufschlagen
entschuldigt bitte die unterbrechung
haben sagt mich einfach so zum lachen
gebracht hätte der kamera lachen
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt natürlich
die prise salz und rheine geben hilft
einfach dass die eier flüssiger werden
und sich besser aufschlagen lassen und
jetzt gebe ich auch noch den zucker mit
dazu und unser vanille extrakt und dann
auf höchster stufe 56 minuten lang
schaumig schlagen oder cremig schlagen
besser gesagt
[Musik]
ihr habt gesehen die eier werden richtig
dick cremig nach nur fünf minuten auf
höchster stufe werk eine küchenmaschine
hat der kann natürlich auch das
handgerät verwenden dauerte ungefähr
sieben bis acht minuten und damit
trockenen zutaten vermischen und nur
ganz kurz einrühren
ich mache den rest jetzt sogar mit dem
teig szavay wenn ihr zu lange ein rührt
dann geht die masse wieder runter und
ist nicht mehr so schön fluffig also der
teig ist somit fertig jetzt brauchen wir
ein backblech daneben benimmt gern meint
natürlich das ist nämlich schön gerade
da gebe ich einfach ein backpapier
obendrauf und den eckigen back rammt ich
verliere euch natürlich die produkte in
der infobox und dann mache ich den ja so
groß wie das bak flächen schreibt euch
aber die genauen maße auf die nichtwahl
nochmal unten in die infobox und dann
füllt ihr ganz einfach den teig 1
[Musik]
für den teig schön glatt verstreichen
und dann kommt die mandel schicht oben
drauf ich liebe das ja nach dem backen
schön knackig und dann sind jetzt
einfach die sauberen hände und verteiler
schön gleichmäßig wie schön kann ein
rührteig bitte aussehen das ist doch
nicht möglich
es ist doch man sieht es ja hier auch
wie man wird jetzt gebacken das ist
schon goldbraune schon gar ist bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze ganz ganz
wichtig bitte vorhalten und da haben
sowie durch hier reinschreiben wie lange
es bei mir gedauert hat und ich sage
euch das im anschluss auch also ist
nachher
[Musik]
ich tippe auf 22 minuten was sagst du
dein gebot 25 mutig im sommer gespannt
der bürgerkrieg der kohle ausgegeben
während der ofen arbeitet können wir
auch schon mal mit der creme
weitermachen ich zeige euch hier heute
zutaten nicht bereitgestellt habe wir
benötigen milchzucker hier habe ich
vanille extrakt und vanillepudding
pulver außerdem kalte schlagsahne und
sahne fest wir kümmern uns jetzt aber
zuerst um und vanillepudding ich geb
einmal das pulver mit etwas von der
milch in eine schüssel und berühre das
gleiche datum den rest dem ich gebe ich
schon mal zum topf und hier könnt ihr
zucker und vanille extrakt auch schon
mit dazu geben die mich jetzt einfach
unter ständigem rühren einmal gerade so
aufkochen dass sie jetzt anfängt
hochzusteigen das sieht man ja auch ganz
gut und dann gehen wir die verwirrte
vanillepudding pulver mischung mit dazu
und lassen das unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufkochen und dann liegt das
ganze auch schon ein paar den pudding
dann einmal umfüllen an der oberfläche
also direkt an der oberfläche mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken dann bildet
sich keine haut und jetzt einmal
vollständig abkühlen lassen und dann
können wir weitermachen arbeitgeber
fleißig und hat schon mal vorbereitet
und das ist jetzt die abgekühlte
variante die löffeln wir morgen so aus
dass wir nicht gemerkt ja und damit
machen wir jetzt weiter das ganze jetzt
einmal mit dem handrührgerät aufschlagen
und dann werde ich gleich auch schon die
sahne mit dem seine fest schlagen
chapeau ich weiß es selber nicht
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die sahne mit einem
teig schrauber untergehoben habt ist die
creme ja eigentlich fertig aber sie wird
bis zur weiterverarbeitung kühl gestellt
das ist ganz ganz wichtig das heißt erst
den tortenboden durchschneiden um in der
so weit ist dann kommt die creme aus dem
kühlschrank und das heißt wir sehen uns
gleich wieder
der boden ist jetzt gut durchgeführt und
er ist wunderschön goldbraun ich wohl
jetzt einmal den boden aus meiner aus
meinem backblech raus es geht doch super
einfach einfach rausziehen und load und
etwas laut ja und jetzt entfernen wir
unseren unseren back ring wagram
tschuldigung eigentlich könnte ich mir
so eine ecke abschneiden im café und am
einfachsten becken aber wann ein kiki
sei geduldig der kuchen muss noch
beschnitten und befüllt werden sie jetzt
hier meine torten säge und stelle ihn so
ein dass das genau die hälfte meines
tages durchschneiden ich guck mir jetzt
erst mal an wie hoch der geworden ist da
müsste ich immer ganz gehört ganze
viereinhalb zentimeter das heißt
ungefähr 225 wo wir es ganz genau nehmen
heute 22 5
[Musik]
ich rate euch dringend dazu die deckel
schon mal vor zu schneiden so wie ich
das gerade gemacht habt ihr könnt euch
dann auch damit alle stücke gleichmäßig
groß sind so ein einteiler neben den
verlinkt ihr euch gerne unten in die
infobox
genauso wie alle anderen sachen und
jetzt fehlen nur noch zwei schritte
indem und setzt die creme geben die auf
dem boden hier habe ich auch wieder ein
programm drumherum gespannt und würde
sie euch auslaufen wenn sie wird erst im
kühlschrank richtig schön fest und dann
geben wir den deckel obendrauf
[Musik]
und jetzt muss das ganze nur noch in den
kühlschrank damit auch die creme schön
fest wird also jetzt auch keinen fall
serien die creme ist ja noch ziemlich
weich aber nach der kür zeit wird so
schön schnittfest gerade noch so weit
dass sie einfach auf der zunge zergeht
ihr müsst das rezept unbedingt
ausprobieren
nachdem sowie und könnt ihr entweder
puderzucker drauf geben für die optik so
ein bisschen also süße braucht es nicht
mehr
oder was ich auch richtig richtig schön
findet die agrikultur ihr nehmt einfach
aprikosenmarmelade erhitzt die
mikrowelle und dann einfach mit dem
pinsel darüber streichen ich glaube ich
entscheide das morgen dann spontan mal
gucken lässt sich überraschen
auf jeden fall ganz ganz ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken schaut unten in
die infobox für alle genauen
mengenangaben und dann freue ich mich
auch über eure fotos mit dem hashtag ig
sketchen auf instagram und teile ich das
auch gerne in meiner instagram story und
das dummchen nicht vergessen sind aber
nicht vergessen die glocke nicht
vergessen
und ja sonst habe ich nichts mehr zu
sagen
und das macht man nicht vergessen ja das
wäre auch wunderschön borders der
traumhaft wenn die mir noch einen
kommentar hinterlassen seite die alle
allerbesten es gibt auf der welt und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal auf die
gsg chinchilla
[Musik]